In this lesson we will be covering IP
addressing. In particular we will be covering IPv4
address structure and allocation. IP stands for Internet
Protocol, and version four is the version of the
protocol that is widely deployed on the Internet to date. Each IP address
is a 32-bit number. And that 32-bit number is formatted in what is called dotted
quad notation. For example, the IP
address for www.cc.tech.edu, is 130.207.7.36. And this
is just a convenient way of writing a
32-bit number. So 130 represents eight bits, and
207 is another eight bit number. Seven is
another eight bit number, as is 36. This structure allows for two to the 32 of
about 4 billion Internet addresses. Now that sounds
like a lot of addresses. As it turns
out it's actually not enough, and we're running out of
IP addresses, as I'll discuss in a later lesson. But even
if we only had to deal with two to the 32
Internet addresses, it's still a lot. Think of it if you
have to store every single IP address as an entry
in a table. Very quickly that becomes an extremely large table.
Where look-ups can be slow and the memory required to store
such a large table might be expensive. So what we need
is a more concise way of representing groups of IP addresses.
There are different ways to group IP addresses and we'll look
at the prevailing method in the next part of the lesson.
But first, let's look at how this was done before 1994.